خبايا جديده عن حاله الحرب في اوكرانيا
اضاءت عليها عشرات الوثائق العسكريه
السريه المسربه من البانتاجون صحيفه
بوليتيكو قالت ان الوثائق كشفت عن وجود
قوات من حلف الناتو باوكرانيا تتبع لفرنسا
وامريكا وبريطانيا
التسريب استدعى ردا سريعا من وزير القوات
المسلحه الفرنسي الذي نفذ اي وجود لقواته
في اوكرانيا الوثائق المسربه اظهرت ايضا
مدى عمق اختراق الولايات المتحده للجيش
والاستخبارات الروسيه وفق صحيفه
الوثائق قد تم تقييما قاتما لقوه اله
الحرب الروسيه كما كشفت موادها ان الجيش
الاوكراني في حاله يرسى لها التقارير
الاستخباراتيه تظهر ان واشنطن تتجسس على
القاده العسكريين والسياسيين لاوكرانيا
فضلا عن حلفاء امريكيين مهمين اخرين وقد
ادت الوثائق المسربه بالفعل الى تعقيد
العلاقات مع الدول الحليفه ما اثار الشكوك
حول قدره الولايات المتحده على الحفاظ على
اسرارها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات